[Music]
dude if there is a body flying around
like it is funny sorry like I can't
believe human bodies can look like that
like they just and it's like what makes
it so funny to me is like it's so
embarrassing like be so [__]
embarrassed if I got hit by a car dude I
would [__] kill myself even if I
survived I'd kill myself especially if
it was on video that's so funny your
worst fear of getting hit by a is being
cringe dude imagine cuz then like every
time you people would like reply about
it all the time and like in your
comments being like remember when you
got hit by a car and I'd be like [__]
dude I would kill myself like that would
be the end of me oh my God if that was a
video like that would be [__] up but I
would want it played at my funeral if I
died cuz that would be really funny we
will projector myit onto my coffin we
will yeah I'll do it that's what gets
Anya off the internet just screen cabs
of her just like this dude that is so
embarrassing cuz like I mean we saw the
video of Drew yeah that that's true yeah
they're pulling it up immediately yeah I
mean like we kind of can see how I would
look if I got hit by a
car bro the fact that your neck still
works after this is dude it barely does
it barely does barely yeah that [__] at
the end where you're kind of it's like
my brain like Lo like look I literally
am stiff as a board like it's you did go
riger
Mor holy yeah see if there was a video
like that of me I'd be so oh my God that
would like you'd be embarrassed yeah
really embarrassed I laugh at things and
you're just going extra hard in this
moment there's a video like that of me
[__] kill I would like never there be
no more attempts only successes yeah
yeah yeah only successes only success in
my book can we just watch Tik Tok
honestly that's kind of my vibe yeah you
both locked in Tik
Tok like yeah yeah yeah like moths to a
flame bro like pleasee dude I need a car
so bad oh yeah and she been driving my
car around she shipped hers to Miami I'm
just so caring and I love my family my
family needed a car and I gave them my
car and I immediately regretted it I was
like I don't [__] have a car now so
what's the move I just don't have a
[__] car I don't know what to
do yeah I've been U blacking everywhere
it's really running me up right now
running up a check $1,000 a day yeah
just going up yeah just like going down
the block and be like U walking there
would be so hard yeah um but yeah I want
to get like an old car but all my
friends are scared that it will like
crumble when I crash I'm literally
scared of her getting I crashed in an
old car and it was horrifying yeah it
hurts but you you'll win not the car I
want the car I I want the Bronco 2 and
like I think in it's first year of being
on the Road 70 people died cuz it's like
has the worst like safy rating but it's
gorgeous that car is gorgeous let's pull
up Bronco 2 Bronco 2 1988 Bronco 2
that's the exact what I want which maybe
I don't need a car that's actually 35
years old but then look up
Defender that's like an expensive car
this one isn't that
expensive yeah like this one is
like it is a sick car
KY
wait no you're not doing it good today
can't do it right now I hope in the
audio they just low pass that so it just
looks like Drew going wait
do it do it do so you want this that's
the car my dreams right there Bronco too
hey girl that's the car that's going to
kill me guys why don't you just buy it
and then put an airbag in it can you um
no you can decapitate in this thing oh
really why like literally the front end
like of it crushes and like everybody
like Falls forward and it like crushes
in and it like turns over really easy so
like it flips a lot and that was like
the big issue is they were super like
the brownco had gotten so popular and
then they were like oh this one's cool
cuz it's like for families like it's
smaller it's like the it's like smaller
than like a Tesla Model Y and people
were like oh this would be perfect for
people who like want to still like go
outdoors and like if you want a
forerunner um but it literally would
flip over all the [__] time and they
just like squish like a tunic can but
that' be kind of a Vibe see getting hit
by a car embarrassing dying in that car
cool iconic yeah it would be iconic it
would be like yeah she died in a Bronco
too yeah dream car she had it for 3 Days
yeah and she passed I mean you could
just this is just the car guy in me you
could like widen the wheelbase and then
at least it wouldn't flip you still
might get crumpled in the front but yeah
I could put 37 in wheels on it yeah yeah
and just make it wide Beef It Up yeah
cuz it is a smaller car like it looks
big but it's actually small like it's as
big as my car how much does a Bronco 2
now there's one for sale in La for 9. 7K
oh but but when they're in really nice
condition they're like 25k like when
they're like actually upheld like will
work I'm also like I don't know if inia
can get an older car because like her
taking it to the that won't happen yeah
she won't take it to if that [__] broke
down on the highway I would get out
calling Uber black to the side of the
[__] highway and leave that [__]
there right I be like if you [__]
want it breaking and take it hot wire it
I don't care the red interior is
beautiful though it's so gorgeous
imagine me smoking cigarettes and just
like making that car disgusting it would
smell like [__] everyone would hate
getting in it it'd be a safety
hazard well then it'd be easy to just
light on fire when you roll it yeah
it'll just explode from all the gases
I've made in it [__] that one's sick
yeah see I like the big body well it's
got the it's got the bar on the front so
you can't get um your head cut off so
cleanly you can't get be decapitated
yeah that might be the four the the
first thing that goes yeah there this is
my dream like just sitting here and
looking at these cars I know I literally
love this this is my dream going on auto
trader going on car for real we do this
brt tr.com we do bring your trailer
Zillow Car Guru bring your trailer rips
man I didn't know you guys were car car
guys that's awesome I'm I'm like not so
much but because the past year I've been
knowing I was going to give my car away
I was like I need a car and I hate new
cars I think they're so [__] butt
[__] ugly and will hold no value and
it's so useless and they need to stop
making them it's a cyber truck it be
worth half a million dollars in 10 years
yeah for real get uh cyber truck is just
a Bronco too they're both human
Cas I wanted one I had a chance to get
one like a couple months ago and I
passed on it and I'm so sad I think
about it every day every day rip I wish
I got it but I really want y this is
what this is what you can do after you
crash the car happen this is what
happens to you yeah my m of four Bronco
parts parthe driver included yeah we
have her spine her left foot and a piece
of her skull a single piece and then
some girl on Tik Tok is going to be like
I went to the best estate sale today I
got part of this girl skull and I Ed it
as my catch all I put all my rings in it
get ready with me as I Thrift parts for
my
Bronco this one has brain matter on it
but we can wash it out I really wish I
was like super balling cuz I want an e
Hummer that's my dream part if I was
going to get a car and I had the bread I
would fully get a Eevee Hummer cuz that
would also be hilarious like me and an
Eevee Hummer that thing is [__]
humongous yeah cuz that's all I really
want it's like I just want a car that
it's like actually comical for me to get
out of like I think they only made like
3,500 of these like on the road like
they were one of the worst selling cars
last year yeah cuz they're so expensive
and like so like not yeah they go 50
miles yeah they got the crab walk though
yeah the crab walk is sick it's fire car
shouldn't be on the market though it's
literally three times the weight of a
normal car and it goes 0 to 60 in like 3
seconds so if I [__] if you piss me off
I could kill
you dude you could destroy a pizza shop
with this oh that's a good compilation
to watch to is like cars driving through
buildings cuz they always get out and
they're
like like what did I I'm sober I swear
what did I do I didn't do that I didn't
do that I didn't do that so funny to be
like no the pedal it got jammed I
dropped my phone got
jammed